Filipinos though vietname they're
good-looking people my tribe me on our
other trick you know the lady boys oh my
Oh Jin and then you go up and then they
have these fat dick I was when I was in
Thailand with like the cast the hangover
and where the lady boys went watch them
dance and one of them was stroking I
think is Brody Stevens and I was like
dude if you went with this [ __ ] it
you are not gay you're not gay because
they're so fat that's what they look
like so you explained to me that second
one in I'd be [ __ ]
literally the this morning like this
first one second one yeah that was all
right this one they're all do you like
the one that looks like the dude in the
back tell them I'll line up look at the
one with the hips that's a cow for me
those were wide hips yeah that's a girl
looks like Tom Brady's lower body what
I'm drawn to that I'm drawn to it look
good trick you man yeah they'll trick
you does she sign today yeah what would
happen is we'd get all the guy on the
ride down the guy on the left no sir you
gotta do better you know you look like
you like a dude who put on a red eye
immediately that loser guys right away
the one in the middle I'd like to I kind
of funky the one on the right would get
away with it cuz she's got cleavage if
it was late at night you get away with
it guy left her like hey bro yeah it's
not here huh
what happens in these situations is
we're hanging out we're drunk good time
you're gonna bathroom I let me go in
there done it I'm like ah
Brendan all right it's mums the word
yeah but there with with oh it was
science like there was one I watched on
TLC man she was she's still killing it I
don't get you man I'll get you you know
some people say booty hoes of booty
holes well I can tell this story um our
boy Stevie I met him out and uh this is
about a year ago maybe I met him out
maybe a little more actually maybe a
year and a half tears and he was with
this just blow out just blow out tits
and ass I mean crazy mouth I was like
what I there's Austin with you go ahead
nope
no this was in Los Angeles met him they
were at crossroads the vegan restaurant
so I was good my boy Travis okay and so
I was going met him good guy I was on my
way to the The Improv met them there and
I went and I went it was a kind of a
first date for him didn't know and I
looked at her and I was like wow she's
very curvy and she got up hugged me gave
me a kiss and went wow you're sexy and I
went this is an interesting situation
forward I was like this is an
interesting Sigma situation but wearing
them like no bra with just he's crazy in
the nipples and I was like and people
were looking at her which she would walk
by it at all um very good question but a
good five eight yeah not too alarming no
not too alarming my my my man made our
radar display a little bit a little bit
a little aggressive she is and and
that's a great live what's funny is that
I went that's a hot dude chick not yet
okay but my but there wasn't in me and
there was a in kind of everybody as she
walked there's something Oh everyone's
attracted to her a little bit like
there's something gonna be but I just
couldn't figure out what was going on
either could Stevie I go where'd you
meet her guy I said what are you
thinking he goes I don't know I I can't
figure it out you know I'm so we hang
we're walking and then she says
something like well I'm there's a lot of
me I'm a lot like a guy in a lot of ways
ah because we were talking about
sexuality and stuff and I was like hmm
so we're walking and I'm looking I look
at her ass look at her body look at her
gait I wonder the way she walks
no that's tough to do and and what
happens is there's an overcompensation
so she's walking super sexy she's making
an effort to just walk super sexy
because her balls are pinching in the
middle of it well well well
maybe but she was wearing there's no way
that balls and [ __ ] could fit in what
she was wearing be surprised you would
be surprised because Levi's gets it done
they were Levi's they were T there were
white jeans dude so anyway he's now
she's sitting on Stevie's lap in the
thing
she's caressing him and stuff like that
and Stevie comes back out and he goes I
don't know where it is
I'm just not attracted to her and I go I
know what it is what she used to be a
fella buddy and he goes do you think and
I go watch this I go right to the people
next whistle the girl that he was with
they go yeah I go
something's up right and they go we
can't figure it out
but there's something up I go like what
do you think and he goes why I don't
want to say you saying his girl goes I
think she might have been a guide
brilliant I went and I agree
long story short he drives her home
Stevie sucks among Steve he does not but
Stevie just goes Stevie goes well you
know I like I said I go you gotta hit it
he goes he goes nope sir hit there and
he said and she says something else
about being a guy she kind of like I
lose to another thing like what she says
I'm usually one of the boys so you can
it's all good we can hang out it you
know why that you know I a lot of times
people transgender people say this
because they're trying to give you hints
because if you do go the bedroom they
don't get beat up yeah and also that's
right there are a lot of reasons but my
mother said sounds like my mother says
something maybe a little bit of the
yellow scuffle well my mother said
something interesting about it my mother
said you might have when you're with
someone like that and I want you to look
this up to see if this is true um he he
may have the skin temperature might be
different it might be more else maybe
and and smell might be different so
there's a different kind of smell a
different kind of deal it's calls good
vo it's just called guys it's called
it's called testosterone over do and you
nuts let's see this skin temperature and
males versus females let's see that this
is my mother the other thing I throws
you off is she referred to his bro so
that's not gonna help you know she know
she didn't know by tempor how difference
for men and women
it is Mondays Medical myth hey you know
men are hotter than women women have
naturally cooler bodies than men well
their circulation of the blood is why
higher core temperature more body fat
and fluctuating hormones huh it's a
stretch might have been burning hotter
it's a stress
pick up no because we pick up on really
subtle cues as human beings like really
subtle [ __ ] pheromones Adam's apple no
you don't hand see that out her butt
hand and you can't hide see and hide
long enough size 14 but she wasn't eater
she was not a big guy or a girl
but but I'd love to see a picture we
pick up on really lose my thing Stevie I
mean a couple things you he doesn't talk
about it here well don't don't give
aways joke here's my thing Stevie might
be into it just to hear me out Steve you
don't keep BBQ me up for this but you've
been in prison bro you're in there quite
some time just the home Stevie's
estrellas right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue Oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]